hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 chinese martial arts action movie
called shadow or ying
the movie revolves around one of the
surrogates of chinese's ancient nobles
and king called shadow who has to
bravely risk his life to prove his
loyalty to his master
the movie begins with commander ziyu who
just arrives at the king's palace and
informs the other that he has challenged
yang kang to a rematch to reclaim jing
city which has been under yang kingdom's
occupation for several years after he
lost a duel with yang kang
the king of pay kingdom is enraged and
thinks that the duel is a bad idea
because it'll destroy the alliance but
the commander makes it clear that it is
a necessary action for their kingdom
after the commander leaves with his wife
xiao i the king tells his minister lou
that he plans to marry his beloved
sister ching ping with yang kang's son
named yang ping to maintain peace
between them while showing to them that
ziyu is acting on his own
later that night in the commander's
residence xiaoi secretly enters a room
that connects to a cave where the real
commander's eu who is severely wounded
is attempting to create the same wound
on the fake xiu's chest whose real name
is jing-jo
he is purposely employed to be the
commander surrogate known as the shadow
to retake jing city
he was taken by ziya's uncle when he was
eight because he looks just like ziyu
and was trained to be a decent shadow
since then jingzhou has wanted to repay
the kindness for saving him from hunger
20 years ago
ziyu promises that he will let jing joe
meet his mother again after the battle
is won
after that jing jo and xiao are returned
to their residence where she teaches
jing how to play goo chung a chinese
pluck zither in the bedroom the fake
commander chooses to sleep on the floor
because he is not the real husband of
xiao i
the next day in an urgent meeting
arranged by the king the fake
commander's eu wants to be beheaded as a
punishment for declaring a war with yang
kang
however the king refuses and decides to
revoke his powers as the commander
instead
before he's dismissed the king demands
to see the wound from yang's saber on
his chest
when the king applies an ointment on it
he realizes that the wound looks fresh
the fake zu claims that the original
wound has healed and he deliberately
slashed his chest as a reminder of his
greatest shame he states that the wound
will never heal until they have
successfully reclaimed jing city
everyone in the room including the king
believes him and lets him leave
after the trial the king makes fun of
ziu's self-inflicted action but his
sister thinks it's an honorable act and
accuses his brother of being a coward
back at the cave jing-jo continues his
training with a real commander who
mimics yang's battle style so that he
would be more prepared for the upcoming
duel
unfortunately jing joe who equips
himself with a metal umbrella weapon is
not able to land a single strike on the
commander
ziu finishes the training by
demonstrating the final blow he took
from yang and then becomes desperately
furious with his surrogate because he's
still not focused
on the other hand the king of pay
kingdom finally receives an answer from
the yang family regarding the marriage
proposal however yang ping proposes to
take ching ping as a concubine instead
he also offers them his personal dagger
as an engagement gift
without doubt the king decides to accept
the proposal which makes ching ping
furious because she wasn't informed
about the plan at all
general tian who thinks that the offer
is an insult finally speaks up shouting
that their kingdom will perish under the
king's reign offended with the statement
the king dismisses him from his position
as the general walks away from the hall
the king attempts to shoot an arrow
towards him but he misses before the
king shoots his second arrow ching ping
intervenes and eventually agrees to the
proposal
meanwhile in jing city yang kang is
testing his son's fighting ability in a
duel
after the training yang kang is
impressed by how commander ziyu who was
actually jin jo has completely recovered
from the wound but his son is optimistic
that pay won't give any trouble to them
as the king just sacked his two best
fighters
back to the cave jing jo is ready for
the next training session before they
start xiaoi suggests jing jo embraces
soft and slow fighting style as the
metal umbrella weapon represents you in
chinese philosophy which is associated
with water and femininity because yin
counters yang she thinks that it will be
more effective to counter yang kang's
fierce and hard fighting style which
represents yang or fire
xiao directly demonstrates the feminine
fighting style and it works
ziyu still doesn't believe her and tells
her to pair with jingzhou with that
technique the pair also managed to dodge
yang kang's signature move
zu finally realizes that it's effective
deducing that there's a hope to beat
yang kang
after that jing joe is dismissed
in the middle of the forest jing zhou
acting as commander ziyu meets
ex-general chian and tells him that he
has finally found the winning technique
to beat yang's kingdom
he then hands over the flute and orders
him to train a hundred convicts who's
recruited by ziyu afterwards he brings
the chaon to meet the real zu in person
where he explains to the general about
jing jo's role as a shadow in his
planned to become the king after
retaking jing city
he also intends to promote chaon into
the commander role if that happens
the next day tian begins the practice
session with the convicts telling them
to wield their umbrella weapons with
feminine moves to beat yang's saber
technique
meanwhile xiao i z you and jing jo are
having a tea time together as tomorrow
as the d-day of the duel and the
commander is optimistic with the result
as the pair returned to their bedroom
jing-jo confesses to shia that he has
been willing to obey the commander
because of her as it's their last night
together shiawa decides to sleep with
him while being watched by ziyu through
the secret hole
in the morning jing-jo arrives at jing
city bringing the yin-yang arena with
him and challenges yang kang to duel as
agreed yang ping senses something as odd
as he comes alone to the city turns out
that tion and 100 convicts are waiting
below the platform
they secretly dive into the water to
enter the city undetected
at the same time tian is startled when
he sees ching ping is sneaking among
them
in the arena the duel which uses the
best of three battle format finally
begins
the first battle is easily won by jing
zhou however yang kang manages to land a
slash on jing joe's chest in the second
round and wins the round
in the final round jing-jo uses his
feminine moves to block yang's signature
saber move causing the saber to be
thrown away
yang reacts fast grabs the saber back
and launches a counter-attack which
manages to hit jingzhou's knee he offers
to call it a draw because jing joe
manages to survive three rounds but he
insists on continuing the duel which
means that it'll be a life or death duel
while most of the guard's attention are
occupied in the duel the convicts sneak
into the city and start eliminating the
remaining guards after that they take
out their new metal umbrella weapons and
begin spinning forwards to dodge the
upcoming arrows while taking the guards
out with the crossbows
the close combat between the guards and
the convicts eventually occurs when a
convict is about to cut down the yang's
banner yang ping appears and kills him
moments later ching ping also shows up
and battles him but then gets slashed in
the stomach
as he walks towards her he questions her
decision to take part in the fight he
thinks that a woman should do cooking
and other things at home when he gets
closer to her ching ping stabs him with
a dagger she got as an engagement gift
instantly killing him
afterwards the banner is toppled down by
tian and the jing city is finally
recaptured in the middle of the final
battle yang kang is distracted by the
fallen banner and eventually becomes
furious when he's about to finish him
off with one of the umbrella blades
jing-jo quickly snaps the blade causing
it to slit yang's throat instead and
kill him
in the evening jing-jo returns to his
childhood house in jing city to meet his
mother only to find that she's been
stabbed to death
suddenly several assassins appear and
attempt to kill him the fight ensues and
the assassins almost kill him until an
emissary comes to the rescue
he then tells jing joe that he's sent by
the king and brings him back to the pays
kingdom
meanwhile the king is very shocked when
he sees his sister's body the following
day the king and the others celebrate
the reclaiming of jing city and the king
personally congratulates the fake
commander for the achievement
at the same time several assassins who
are ordered by the king arrive at ziu's
residence in an attempt to assassinate
the real commander's eu
back in the hall the king suddenly
dismisses everyone in the room except
lou xiao i and jingzhou
turns out that the king knows that lou
has been reporting to yang all this time
and ends his life for being a traitor
surprisingly the king is also aware that
jing joe is a shadow of zu and offers
him to become the new commander because
the king believes that he's loyal and
obedient not long after an assassin
arrives at the hall with a box
containing ziya's head however the box
is empty and the assassin stabs the king
from behind he then removes the mask and
reveals himself as zhiyu
zhiyu then provokes jingzhou by telling
him that it was the king who ordered to
kill jing jo's mother
he then orders his shadow to finish the
king off to avenge his mother as jing-jo
reaches for the sword zeu attempts to
kill him from behind but the shadow is
prepared and repeatedly stabs ziu
afterwards he puts the mask back and
pulls the king's dying body next to
ziu's body
he subsequently stabs the king to his
death and then purposely puts the sword
in ziu's hand
jingzhou walks out of the hall and
announces to the others that the king
has been assassinated but he managed to
kill the culprit however tian does not
seem to believe him
at the end of the movie xiao runs
towards the door and looks out towards
an opening with an unclear expression
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching